okay welcome everybody
i hope uh this new holiday edition
of the into the impossible podcast uh
is finding everybody in good health and
in good spirits and getting ready
for a sweet and a happy new year
as rabbi wilby undoubtedly knows i am a
cosmologist
so i want to wish him as we cosmologists
will do wish him an
early 5781st year
uh since the creation of the universe in
the fiery big bang
universe accomplished a lot rabbi it's
very impressive so
my guest today is a gentleman that i've
been following
at a distance stalking if you will for
more than two years now
dying to get him on the show and i
thought this would be a great chance to
do it
he's been on the podcast with my good
friend eric weinstein the portal podcast
he runs a podcast which is my weekly
listening
uh for shabbat which is a podcast
production that he makes out of the
sinai temple
first i want to introduce him his name
is rabbi david j wolpe
he's the max webb senior rabbi of sinai
temple
in los angeles and he's not only
america's rabbi but he's the most
influential rabbi in america
uh so says newsweek magazine and he's
one of the most
50 most influential jews in the world
according to the jerusalem post what do
they know you know they're
they're really biased yeah i would i
wouldn't buy there
yeah they might be slightly biased uh
sinai temple of course is in the
westwood district of los angeles
it's the oldest and largest conservative
congregation in the greater los angeles
area
uh it's a real pleasure to have you here
rabbi uh thank you so much for
uh for joining us on the into the
impossible podcast
thank you and i want to thank you at the
outset for giving scientific
confirmation to the uh
jewish day to the universe there 57-81
you said
that's right since the big bang
that may that may ruffle a few feathers
in the scientific community there
that's right you came right out in seven
well i know that you are a fan of robert
jastrow's book god and the astronomers
and maybe if we have time we'll talk
about that because
of course it was a you know some some
jews have played slight uh slight roles
in the discovery of different aspects of
the universe's age and i want to talk
about that and kind of some of the
special uniquely jewish or perhaps uh
specifically jewish aspects but before
we get into that i want to ask you
um if you were abducted by aliens we're
going to get it deep into aliens because
i know
okay i know uh i have to appeal to your
science fiction loving side
but uh if you were to be abducted by
aliens they randomly come to westwood
they pick a random person at large uh
happened to pick you
and they ask you uh who are you uh how
do you answer that question
so this has happened of course no i'm
just kidding um
so i i mean if they ask who i am
the interesting thing of course is that
among re-earthlings uh
what the answer to that question is
generally what do you do for a living
so i suppose i would say i'm a rabbi um
but if i was abducted by aliens uh i
might say
that you know i'm a human being that i
have a child
uh that i uh i believe in certain things
pretty strongly uh and uh
that i hope they're they have benevolent
intentions towards my
fellow earthlings so it's very
interesting that you describe yourself
of course as a as a father i think
that's
part of the root of the word rabbi is it
not uh
derivative uh at least in some sense of
the word of which means father is that
not
correct i guess rav could be similar and
it also means teacher
and teachers and parents are very
intertwined
in the jewish tradition absolutely
you're supposed to honor your teacher
the way you honor your parent um
and yeah i do also i had a father
who was a rabbi as well and to whom i
was very close
and thought very highly of so i suppose
that role does have
particular significance to me
but if you were asking me how would i
define myself professionally
i would define myself as a rabbi i write
i teach
i'm i'm
someone who also has deep
interests in philosophy literature
other areas outside of specifically
jewish
texts and teachings but that's my
foundation still
yeah that's sort of what i was
interested in and kind of
honing in on because you do so much
you've written books
you are obviously a rabbi that's your
profession um
yeah um you told me offline you went
into it for the money which is the same
reason
i became a professor at a state exactly
at a state university
uh that's right and especially a
cosmologist at that um
but you know i think it's it's very
interesting and i once
heard at schule once at synagogue once
you know someone asked me you know
you know what are you or you know who
are you and i said i'm a cosmologist
and usually that's a conversation
starter it's like nobody ever meets a
jew
and they find out oh you're jewish and
it's like oh you know past the
past the pickles something interesting
about being a jew there's something
interesting and it's not better or worse
it just
is there's something interesting about
being a cosmologist and the guy said
no that's what you do that's not who you
are
but i think with a rabbi it is sort of
who you are i mean you're the only guys
who can get paid to work on shabbos
without violating you know the laws of
melania so it's also true that it's not
a role in the sense that someone doesn't
say
oh there's joe he's a friend of mine by
the way he's also a lawyer yes
instead you are always the rabbi
and there are advantages and
disadvantages to that but when someone
sees me in the supermarket that's the
rabbi in the supermarket
where they see me taking a walk early in
the morning that's the rabbi taking a
walk
and and it is astonishing
um how difficult it is for
almost anyone to separate
the role from the person my father
had a good friend who once started to
tell him a dirty joke
and stopped himself and said oh rabbi
if you weren't here could i tell you a
joke
so that sense of the
pervasive now it's less true now i think
than it was
you know 40 years ago or 50 years ago
um but but it is
still deeply true do you ever wish that
you
couldn't that you could be sort of free
of that expectation you know you'd hear
a lot more dirty jokes
um yeah i i should say your repertoire
uh
and your daily pulpit off the pulpit uh
seminar um
i do love jokes really good they're
hilarious and i do have some that i
can't tell
but but uh yeah the the answer is there
are moments when i wish i could escape
it but but by and large i i think that
it's uh
i'm glad for for what i have
yeah and uh i want to talk to you
about you know a lot of the times as a
rabbi my understanding is that
uh you have to listen to a lot of what
your congregation wants and
there's the old adage you know two jews
three opinions
um do you ever feel like you want to be
asked questions do you ever feel like
there's questions that you were just
dying that you wish somebody would ask
you
um i don't i wonder whether there are
specific
questions that uh that i haven't been
asked that i would be
desperate to be asked i don't think so
again
um i think that i get generally a fairly
broad
range of questions um but
but i i have noticed that um
what has happened to the jewish
community in general and certainly
to my community is
questions of jewish learning which used
to be
part of the staple of being a rabbi
are much less frequent than they are
that's for two reasons
one because the jewish community is less
interested in questions of jewish
learning
and the second is because
to be perfectly honest a lot of the
things that people ask me
they can google and find out the
information as easily maybe more
reliably and more detail than anything i
could tell them
and so i tend to get questions more of
judgment
and of opinion and less of knowledge
that has changed that has changed yeah
i've heard
it said uh you know the most cited
academic in history is a woman by the
name of marilyn vos savant
because she's published in parade
magazine and it's
always like you know questions that are
coming in are like uh what was the uh
you know capital of phoenicia and
like 13 bce or whatever and it's like
easily things you could look up and
similarly too with uh the new york times
crossword puzzle
there used to be a tip line you could
call in for a tip line and i used to you
know run up my uh my mom's credit card
bill
uh by doing that but yeah you're right
there are so many things but when
judaism is a very legalistic
uh and it's it's not sort of
consensus-based it's more i would say
it's more
authority based and i wonder could you
explain to me
how you see conservative judaism people
might be familiar with you know the
majority of jews are what we call
reformed jews correct
yeah these days probably so so generally
conservative judaism which was once the
majority tradition in america but now is
not
conservative judaism was an attempt to
look at with modern historical
tools at the tradition and assert that
it changed
historically and needed to change
historically
and therefore um part of the jewish
legal system
should be taking into account the
different situations in which jews found
themselves
uh i think that that's used to use
slogans like tradition and change
um positive historical judaism
what has happened in the 28th first 20th
and 21st century
is the discovery that as soon and this
is my own interpretation of it
as soon as you remove god said you have
to do this
you are in them the area of you should
do it for the following reasons
and so conservative and and by extension
reformed jews spend their time saying
you should practice judaism because and
we have lots of the causes and many of
them i think are very compelling and
very beautiful
none of them is as compelling as because
the creator of
everything that exists told you to do it
so i do believe that for non-literalist
judaism there is an ideological struggle
which is very very hard to make
conservative jews in theory still can
kosher still keep shabbat
um still observe the holidays but it is
an uphill struggle
and you know typically it's uh you know
people will
will kind of rely on rabbis almost to
get their
opinion on the existence of god and so
forth and i think that there's an awful
lot of pressure it must feel like to
to be in that position uh especially
when there's aspects of loss and
growth and connection and even you know
the pressure of keeping the jewish
the jewish kind of culture and and and
tradition alive yeah go ahead
so the the these days there are two
different kinds of pressure
and they are uh and they're different
but they're at least equal one is the
pressure that you enunciated about how
do you keep the jewish tradition alive
after all you've given your life to it
and
and and it's so hard we were talking
about the fact that
we're doing services online so different
from anything we've ever done and how
difficult that is and how do you
maintain it
the other pressure which will not
surprise any of your listeners
is the pressure for political statements
because the jewish
polity like every other polity right now
in america
is bitterly unalterably um
and and savagely even divided
between the right and the left uh and
they are living
in real alternative realities
in which the concerns of the other do
not impinge
and if you are a rabbi as i am and you
have
people on both sides of that divide
which i do
um you cannot split the difference
um and so there is a constant
b on my side b on my side that i get
you should see my email my email is like
basically divided
between um this side is right and that
side is right and this
or or more accurately and more commonly
that side is a jerk the other side is a
jerk
um and so it's become very very
difficult to
uh to navigate those uh those political
waters
and do you feel like that those
political waters really
are getting more and more turbulent in
these particular times that we live or
live in now oh yeah you were very
outspoken this summer and took very
courageous stands you know when it came
to the black lives matter movement
and i think that but uh do you feel i
would pressure
i want to be really clear we did not
take a stand on the black lives matter
movement
just for this reason what i did was i
put a sign up on the synagogue that said
we stand with our african-american
brothers and sisters against racism
didn't talk about black lives matter
specifically because
black lives matter right now especially
in the jewish community is extremely
polarizing
because some of the leaders of black
lives matter have made anti-israel and
even anti-semitic statements
and yet i thought that it was really
important for jews to make a statement
about racial justice
and so that was a perfect example of how
i wanted even our own black members
because we have black jews in the
synagogue to know
we care about this we notice this we
want to stand
up with you but i also want to avoid
the political turbulence that comes with
any slogan
wasn't easy uh and some people really
didn't like on both sides but there you
go
yeah and when you um when we think about
you know the part of the objective of
many rabbis i think that's admirable is
to increase
the the participation both at the
younger you know kind of population
level it's often said that you know
judaism is a dying religion i mean
that's that's been said you know more
times than they said mark twain
or alfred nobel was dead in the case
that i'm interested in
um but you know i i find a lot of times
with the kids that i see at the hillel
here at uc san diego
you know they're kind of defined by or
they see judaism if they think about it
at all as kind of split between well the
israel-palestine conflict or
the holocaust and none of the those
aspects really appealed to me when i
became what's called a bowel teshuva
a returnee to judaism after being an
altar boy in the catholic church as i
described in my book
we won't get into that now but uh but
the point is
you know coming back to be to the
religion of my birth
uh was not motivated by guilt over the
holocaust or
uh or or perhaps you know wanting to
take sides politically and zionistic
reasons
how do you you know the kind of famous
hillel you know convince me standing on
one leg
not that god exists or whatever but just
why should a young person why should an
old person
you know i came back to judaism at age
30 and learned hebrew etc was very
difficult
but uh convince me on one leg you know
what sort of what's sort of your
approach to
positive judaism rather than reactionary
well i wrote a book called why be jewish
and in it i say um
i say it is the oldest continuous
tradition in the world that teaches
people how to grow their souls
and that's my principle opening gambit
is if you want to learn how to grow your
soul and i believe that that's actually
the reason
why we exist in this world is to do so
um judaism is here to teach you how to
do it
and also it allows you to join the
people
you will never be alone in the world if
you're part of this people
um and it teaches you how to work
in the world to make the world better
all those things i believe are true it
is also true that although
it it isn't the case for you for many
jews um the historical experience of the
jewish people
of which the holocaust and the founding
of the state of israel are
the great events of the last 500
000 years those are
very powerful in spurs of identity
um i was in fact before kovid came upon
us i was supposed to lead
march of the living this year when you
bring uh
people to auschwitz birkenau
and and march between them and many many
many young people
have done that and some of them go on to
to israel and they find it an
extraordinarily
powerful awakener of their own religious
uh and spiritual attachments so
it's true that it's not true it doesn't
work for everyone but for many it does
and when i think about uh yeah and it's
not to say that those weren't
influential i've had been lucky enough
to have on my
podcast uh rose schindler who with her
husband
max uh both survived the holocaust case
auschwitz birkenau and uh she's uh she's
a tremendous force i just talked to her
uh for my my birthday she gave us a call
uh
happy birthday by the way thank you
rabbi thank you very much and whatever
yes it is it's another lap around a lap
around the the
the sun and actually maybe that will
segue nicely into what i was going to
ask next which is
you know um we think about why is it so
important that the torah as we're going
to be reading not too long from now in
the weekly cycles
that the beginning of the universe why
is that
the foundational event along with the
exodus from egypt what makes those so
foundational that the rabbis in their
wisdom put those as the
foundational things that we say on all
holidays why why do we remember
you know for example the exodus from
egypt not only on passover
but every saturday every friday right
so i think that it's it's beautiful and
important the way you paired them
because uh there is a
uh there's a philosophical problem about
god about transcendence and imminence
how could god be so far away and still
so close
and without entering into the philosophy
of it
you've just summarized the imagery of it
which is
here is god who created the universe
which makes god infinitely greater than
everything that is but the same god
cared enough about the fate of these
individuals
in the tucked away in this corner of the
cosmos
to make sure that their suffering was
was ended and so i think those are the
reasons it's that
there's the there is as one uh jewish
philosopher you the lady put it there's
the god of the philosophers and the god
of abraham isaac and jacob
and both of them play a part in judaism
um so you were going to say yeah
you recently said and and that really
brings up another
thought in my mind you recently said in
your off the pulpit podcast
you you really said you know one of the
most important mitzvahs is
is essentially the mitzvah of of
forgetting and
uh or the trait i would say that maybe
it's a character trait the middle
media of forgetfulness of course the
torah
you know implores the jewish people to
never forget what the people
known as amalek did how do you square
those two things you know on one hand
we're commanded
another hand we're remembering what
happened that we were slaves in egypt
and yet how do we forgive you know i've
i have wonderful friends that live in
germany you know for example
uh paul how do we reconcile those twin
you know kind of the forces that are
opposing
so first of all i mean those twin forces
exist both in the command to amalek it
says wipe out their memory don't forget
which is a way of saying forget them
don't forget to forget them
um which guarantees memory but
forgiveness and forgetting are not the
same thing
um the uh adam mitch nick the polish
dissident once said uh
i'm for amnesty but not amnesia and i
think that the same thing is true here
judaism doesn't ask you to forget the
bad things that have been done
and also i think asks you know when you
mention germany
there are very very very few people in
germany still alive today
who did bad things to the jews in the
second world war
and the children of evil people do not
themselves bear the responsibility
for their parents deeds um however
having said that
if you do forget it is the it's the
unmastered past
that controls you it's not the things
you remember
uh we learned that uh you know that's uh
it certainly goes back to freud for that
matter goes back to greek
um literature it's when in even jewish
literature when you forget
where you came from who you are then
you're liable to go astray when you
remember
then you have a direction so um
i think that that's now there there is
as you mentioned there's strategic
forgetting in some ways
but i think that judaism clearly does
stand on the side of memory
and uh and zachary to remember
is a commandment so we have a question
from
we've got a pretty good outsized
audience now so i'm going to take one
from
fabian mango fabian mango he says for me
there's always been a clear
difference between church the christian
organization
and the actual religion slash would you
know in other words
his personal relationship with god is
there such a difference in judaism
not not nearly as much and i'll tell you
why
um this is a wonderful point and and
fabian
uh i i have occasion to make this point
to both christians and jews
judaism is not a religion christianity
is a religion
because today if you believe in jesus
you're a christian
if next week you decide you know what i
don't believe any of that stuff you're
not a christian anymore
judaism works differently
if tomorrow i say all that rabbi stuff
brian i was wrong i don't believe in god
i don't believe in judaism i'm still
jewish
too bad because what judaism is
is a religious family that is religion
is at the heart of it but it's familial
that's why you're born jewish and that's
why
you can you can not want to be part of
the family you still
are the only way in judaism that you
leave is if you choose another family
that is jews who converted to
christianity even though
strictly speaking that wasn't recognized
by jewish law
they were read out of the jewish
community um
so when you say i don't like the
synagogue it's perfectly believe me it's
a long jewish tradition to not like the
synagogue not like the rabbi
there's an old old old jewish joke about
a guy
who caught fire keep it clean right
he finds a jew on a desert island and he
has two synagogues
and he says so you're alone here what do
you need to build two synagogues for he
goes well this one
i pray in and that one i wouldn't set
foot into in other words the idea like
that you dislike a synagogue that is
an old idea yeah but the establishment
of the religion
is not separate from the religion
that is judaism is a religion and i want
to say one more thing about
is a religious family and they're
inextricably intertwined i want to say
one more thing
people say to me sometimes i'm spiritual
but i'm not religious
and what that means to me is i want to
feel things but i want to do things
i actually don't have a lot of respect
for these spiritual but not religious
ideas yeah
if you tell me you're spiritual but not
religious i want to know how much money
do you give to
to charity because religion
is the enactment of what you feel
and that's why if you're religious you
got to go to committee meetings and you
have to go to prayer services and you
have to deal with other people
and there's politics involved politics
by the way almost always means i didn't
get what i want
when someone tells me there's too much
politics in the synagogue i know they
didn't get what they want that someone
else did
um but i love the old story about the
guy who comes to the rabbi and he says
you know rabbi
i'd go to your synagogue but honestly
too many hypocrites there
there have i think here and he goes you
know you're right but there's always
room for one more
so we all have that same impulse it's
like i want to be above it i don't want
to fight but the fight is where
the things get done yeah that's where
the things get done yeah that's that
oh go ahead i was gonna say that's why i
actually have
a less cynical view of politics than
most people do
because i know that it's not nearly as
easy to get stuff done in a political
world as people might think
yeah you know politics is sort of the
highest expression
of you know the ultimate building blocks
at least of humanity
and how we actually enact and relate to
one another
actually getting back to what you said i
think i had this conversation
with ben shapiro on his sunday special
last year exactly at this time
and uh i said you know most people say
they're agnostic you know a scientist if
they'll say that they're not atheist
and i always say oh yeah well which um
which you know church do you not go to
because it's the same one as richard
dawkins
the one that he doesn't go to and you
know the separation of active
participation
i always say you know i don't know rabbi
if i believe in god
but i believe in religion i believe
there is a value to religion
and i think you know i am i am an
agnostic in that sense that i am
constantly questioning constantly
searching uh i think it was ellie wiesel
who said you know a jew cannot be
it you can be angry at god but a jew
can't be without god
uh how do you come down on that side of
that of that uh
i mean i agree i think that god is
central to the jewish tradition and
uh not believing in god but actually
and i think that right i also think that
that what
how you think about god i don't even
want to say what god is
but how you think about god is much
much more various than most jews
or christians for that matter um know
or suspect and the reason that so is
that they stopped their religious
education when they were 13
which is a tragedy because
adult sophisticated thought about
the realities of god is adult
sophisticated thought
just like in any other field cosmology
yeah that's in fact that's another thing
i brought up with ben on my conversation
i said
you know einstein didn't ask what
happens if i travel at the speed of
light and look into a mirror until he
was in his 20s and it was good that he
didn't he said
because he would have asked the smartest
person he knew his dad and his dad would
have said oh it's just happened you know
nobody knows
and he would have accepted that as a
seven-year-old or a 13 year old
and i always think of these great jewish
atheists carl sagan
um whose wife i've had a widow i've had
on my show and his daughter i've had on
my show and they're both
you know devoutly uh secular people but
i asked them as i'll ask you at the end
of this conversation
uh in about 90 minutes no i'm just
kidding and uh
at the proper time as it comes to the
end of the hour but you know i asked
what was
what is your ethical will um and i'll
ask you that what would you put in this
ethical will to to andrewian who's carl
sagan's widow
and she says to you know to act justly
to love mercy
and to walk humbly and i was like ah
you're missing us
you know three words at the end with
your god
and no that's intentional she views the
wisdom
of our tradition not as superior but she
and she obviously doesn't practice at
all
but but that there is value and that we
give up i i said you know another thing
i say frequently is
what if i gave up or what if i said at
age 13
or a 13 year old comes to me and says
you know professor keating
i know all there is about physics
einstein was wrong i said get out of
here you little pisha
you know it's my uh my grandpa where are
you bubby and zadie used to call me
right
so um so i'd say yeah forget about it no
no one maybe in math you might be able
to come up with something but
13 years old you need so much wisdom you
need so much
experience as an experimental physicist
especially no 13 year old can do it
and so i would discount it and now
seemingly i would also
not take the advice of a 13 year old
young man
i.e myself when i decide oh this is all
supernatural shenanigans
and i think right really does a
disservice i mean that's my kind of one
leg conversion
is is that you know you're missing out
on so much in our tradition it doesn't
even matter if you're jewish or not
there's so much
in there and people are asking in the
chat are you know aren't all these
religions the same aren't
all these you know the fact that judaism
and christianity etc and islam come
from the abrahamic tradition isn't that
sort of a proof of god or
or some commonality what do you think
about that so here's the question
i mean the way that i think of religions
is that they are different languages to
speak to the same ultimate reality
and and that's why some of my
jewish colleagues do and will
get upset when i say this that's right
it is not my job to argue judaism's
superiority right it is my job to argue
judaism's excellence
and the reason i say that is i have to i
want to be intellectually honest
i never was a muslim i never was a
christian i never was a jane i never was
a buddhist
so for me to say listen the sikhs
don't have it right the jews do when i
know
100 000 if that
about what it is to be a sikh compared
to what i know it is to be a jew
is it's absurd so
i i don't i try not to pronounce
on the truth claims of other
religions because i don't think that
it's useful or important
what is useful and important is what
your religion makes of you
and there i believe that judaism
has a has an extraordinarily strong
claim in the world
um that it has made a remarkable devoted
capable um contributing people
not perfect obviously but who is
uh and so i
i without understanding what god is or
beginning
to think i have the slightest glimpse i
do believe that in living a jewish life
i am in some way living
in conformity with the way that god
would want me to live
on the portal uh podcast with eric
weinstein our mutual friend
uh you said something to the effect that
uh you
almost believe that uh belief in god is
almost as generative
as grammar is according to one of my
previous guests noam chomsky
you know grammar is sort of an intrinsic
quantity
that is expressed differently as you
said religion is expressed differently
uh in what sense do you did you mean
that and then i have a follow-up
question about that relating to prayer
which is which is my stumbling block so
first of all
i meant it in whatever way will separate
me from noam chomsky
but but that's a separate that's a
separate issue
but i i i would say
um the vastness of the possibility
of conceptions of god forget the
vastness of god which is infinitely
vaster than anything i can imagine
i mean this is what i said i don't
remember if i said this on eric's
podcast
i sometimes tell teenagers
can you when you were two years old you
know what it is to be a 13 year old
and they say obviously no i have no
two-year-old has no idea what it is to
be a 13 year old
and i say well god is greater in
proportion to you
than you are to a two-year-old so you
didn't say that but
how do you know like you did say that on
eric's podcast that's great i mean
that's
that's how that i'm expressing judaism's
belief just so that you understand that
from the jewish tradition
you can't possibly really talk about god
and and yet the idea of god
is in fact so generative as you say
that it explodes into a million
different
paths of life ways of understanding
traditions and so on
um and uh and
and i believe i will say this i believe
that
every spiritual and religious tradition
takes inspiration from and in some way
intuits
the same ultimate reality that i will
say
how they get there and what they do with
that varies
you know enormously enormously all the
different expressions that could take
right
um one of my uh uh commentators uh who
goes
i think that's the hebrew name rust in
peace uh says
uh he understands or she understands the
cultural aspect to religion
just not why it's those of us that want
evidence
before believing are the ones who are
thought to be strange
i don't know it's just an honest
position what's let's say you rub on
okay
first of all i i don't think anybody
calls you strange i mean if they do
that's silly to say that an intellectual
position is strange um
what i would say is that you're making a
category mistake
i believe a category mistake is like
saying
brown is long that is you're applying
the wrong category
to something because you're applying the
kind of proof that you use for a
scientific proposition to something that
is not a scientific proposition
it is rather an orientation of life it
is like saying i want proof that life is
worth living before
i open my eyes in other words it's a
fundamental posture towards the universe
um that's why i don't think of god as an
entity that you either believe in or you
don't believe in
god is a lived reality in your life and
you can live in such a way as to bring
that reality into your life or not
um that's why i always found like
what happened with that set when i when
i had debates with sam harris or
christopher hitchens richard dawkins or
so on
the debates that i thought the part of
the debates that i thought were fruitful
and real
were is religion good for the world but
the parts of the debates that were
really just you know can i be funnier
than you
are is god real because they were
applying the wrong standard i think to
the wrong question
which is god is as real
as my consciousness in moments when i
feel god and i don't want to say that i
am i mean i'm not one of those
religiously gifted people that feels god
at every moment but when i do god is as
real as my consciousness and to ask me
is my consciousness real
is to ask a question that has no real
purchase for me so if you're gonna say
i won't believe in god until i get the
evidence then what i would say to you
is you're not even on the path that
would lead you there anyway so of course
you won't
get that evidence um because if you were
you would see certain things as evidence
like the existence of the world
or the reality of love or the fact that
two and two equals four
which is astonishing or the fact that
your mind can comprehend the fact that
two and two equals four
on and on and on and on um because
uh for most of us just the
what what one uh jewish philosopher
abraham joshua heschel
calls radical amazement is the beginning
of belief
you know what do you make of these you
know there are many different
um uh kind of approaches to the question
of
proving god's existence i feel those are
all fruitless
and the proof to me is that you know
many of them rely on
say scientific consilience when the
scientific method
is predicated on an adversarial kind of
striving for truth which i want to get
into if we have time
uh the the commonality between what i
call the jewish method and the
scientific method
uh maybe if we have time we'll get to
that but it's more important that i ask
these questions first and that's
you know what you hear things i've heard
from from rabbis that i respect and love
you know oh the proof is that all the
kosher animals are listed you know
there's no
there's no hyper pigs or quantum you
know whatever
that are you know or there's only one
animal i mean they're cute things or
the bible codes that's another i have a
very very loving deep relationship with
with rabbis and friends that believe
deeply in the bible codes and so forth
well i
they should read they should read jeff t
gay writing about the bible first of all
the bible codes are
are easily easily i think
um disproven uh it's not even hard to
disprove them
and and it requires so much intellectual
um press dedication i'll put it that way
to uh to maintain the bible codes is
very funny you change spellings of
things
anyway um i don't know i don't believe
that that the creator of the universe
left behind a new york times crossword
puzzle so that you would know
that that the creator of the universe
really exists which is also in moby dick
which is also it makes right it makes
god so
absurdly small right um
that that uh that i it's one of those
cases
of uh of the necessity of bringing god
down
to the narrowness of my own mind right i
prefer episode
simpson what is the opposite of symbols
right exactly so i often find that the
people
want to have that you know they oh
you're a cosmologist you know and
and can you give me you know some
reasons to strengthen my faith and i
you know i always say yeah it's it's
sort of interesting that we
we put so much stock in this in both
scientists nowadays we see that in the
covid crisis of course
we see the debates that are taking place
on university campuses about global
warming and other things not even
debates but
but just these heated discussions and
then i'll give a talk about the origin
of the universe and someone will say
what do you think about global warming
and i'll say well i hope when you have
somebody speaking about you know climate
change
and somebody asks you ask the speaker a
question about uh the origin of the
universe
that the speaker has enough legitimacy
you know to say integrity to say well
why don't you talk to a cosmologist
but i i think it's a natural thing that
people sort of idolize science and
they've come
to this role and you're of course in the
capital of idolatry right now in los
angeles california where
hollywood rules do you think idolatry is
intrinsic
to the human to human nature i mean it's
so much in the torah in the ten
commandments it appears couple times
alone and
the question why is it there like i
don't i don't like want to bow down to a
statue of ball you know anymore no you
don't
not anymore you don't but for a long
time you did not you no balls but yeah
the desire to worship is deep in human
beings
um and i would say look i i think you
see it in the political sphere too
um people feel deeply attached
beyond uh so much so that that when you
approach somebody about the flaws of the
political figure they love
they can't really hear it or they say
well yeah but that doesn't matter
because we really do have a venerative
capacity we
venerate things um and uh
and i would just also say the reason
that idolatry at least again to recur to
heschel since i mentioned him before
there's a beautiful phrase about
idolatry he says look
it's not idolatry it's not about the
fact that you
carve this statue and you say this
statue is god and god gets insulted
they said you know god is big god can
take the inside
the problem he says is that there is a
real image about in this world
and it's in every human face and when
you point to other things and make
them important instead of human beings
then you've done something wrong
and so if we took each other
seriously as images of god i think
that we would act very differently
towards one another and
if we understood that we were all
we all shared that we wouldn't assume
that there are certain people
who are so far above the flaws that that
the devil the rest of us
that we would worship them but it
doesn't we don't work that way
and i mean do you so if it's part of
something deep in the human psyche
is it safe to say that you have your own
idols rabbi i mean was it
was it a a huge accomplishment we became
the max webb
you know senior rabbi for example is
that something you were striving for
that could be coming no
no not not that um not that in fact i
never
thought i was going to be a synagogue
rapper i wanted to be a professor
and a writer it was a somewhat
circuitous root it is to become a
synagogue rabbi
um and and also idolatry generally at
least in my
in my experience it's not about oneself
there are people whom i
admire tremendously who it's hard for me
to hear
negative things about and and i'm not
objective about them
um so yeah that's absolutely true
and uh and there are people whom i've
met
in my life um that i came to them
with uh you know with a sense of
of beyond normal admiration
um and so i think that that impulse
and in fact i'll tell you weirdly i'll
tell you the time that i most understood
the impulse to worship a human being an
idolatry
um so i've had a couple of health crises
i've had
lymphoma and chemotherapy and i also had
a brain tumor and i had a couple brain
surgeries
and the first time i had a brain surgery
after i i still didn't know whether
it was going to be uh you know
life-ending or not or
malignant or anyway the guy who
the doctor at ucla who had operated on
me came into my room
not long after i i recovered
consciousness
and i remember feeling at the moment i
first saw him this
inexplicable up rush of
worship it's like this wasn't a person
right
and i and i also remember at the same
time being astonished by it and thinking
to myself
oh this this is the feeling
that people have when they worship
someone
um and now later on i saw him again he
returned to being a human being but i
will never forget
that sense of this is a god in my room
um and i realized also at the time and i
have seen this
certainly with rabbis and others i
realized also how
distorting and dangerous that can be to
the person
to whom it is directed because
they think of themselves go ahead no i
just want to ask you i mean
i so there's a statement i think in the
talmud i mean everything's in the talmud
there's 2700 pages there uh but one of
it's like you know halacha
or jewish law can become a form of
idolatry
and i don't even think religion can be a
form of idolatry and the proof of that
is all the things that aren't religions
that are
forms of of religion in other words
atheism can be a form of religion
environmentalism
they all have wonderful aspects and and
truth seeking at some level
but is it not possible that you know
even judaism
even halachic judaism or even you know
conservative orthodox reform
could be a form of idolatry yes you can
make you can worship
anything beyond what it merits and
deserves no question about it
um yeah and i want to ask you uh when it
comes down to
you know as you said people have this
innate desire to worship i want to talk
about worship
i i personally find it very hard you
know i know you've never been asked you
know to solve someone's problems in
judaism
but uh this isn't your synagogue's
problem right so this is my problem
i i can relate to judaism on an
intellectual level i love studying the
talmud i love reading the torah
i love looking for connections and just
like wonderful things that
apply today i mean once one great
example is you know there's
something called the shopkeeper law in
judaism which states that you're not
allowed to go into a physical store
and ask the merchant for the price of
something when you know for sure you're
not going to buy it
and and and why is that what's wrong
with that you know you're stealing
the hopes of somebody you're there's a
sensitivity that you need to have
to every human being and call the homer
all the more so
to uh to you know people that you love
and people in your life
but you're not allowed to get people's
hopes up i love those kinds of things i
love thinking about those kinds of
things
uh but my question to you is what about
prayer i mean can you be a jew
obviously you can't be a jew and not you
know have god in the sense that you're
confronting god
can you be a jew who doesn't pray or
cannot pray
you can of course you can you can be a
jew who does almost anything
um but i would say this uh i i like
this this is my favorite image of prayer
and it may help
so there was a uh 17 an 18th century
rabbi leona medina an italian rabbi
and when i read his image of prayer
never left me
he said imagine
that you're standing on the shore and
you see a guy pulling his boat to the
shore
if you were mistaken about mechanics in
motion you might think he was pulling
his the shore
to the boat and when people pray they
make the same mistake
they think what they're doing is pulling
god closer to them i want this
i will pray for it so god will do it the
butler
but he must fight but in fact he says
what you're doing when you pray is
you're pulling yourself closer to god
and if you rise from your prayer now i'm
riffing on what he said if you rise from
your prayer a better person
a more sensitive person a more aware
person your prayers answer
if what you want from your prayer is to
move god i mean i remember again to
return to the same
to the same thing when i was sick i
remember thinking is it really
true that because some people are start
praying for me
that god's gonna look down and say okay
wolfy has someone praying for him i'm
gonna save him but the guy in bed three
i have heard nothing i've heard nothing
no
let him go i don't believe god works
that way
but i don't want a god that works that
way i don't want to god i agree
but i do believe that the prayer
strengthened me
made me feel less alone all of that i
still could have died
but but that prayer worked
yeah and i mean i obviously feel like it
might be the same way
the piece of advice for myself that goes
you know you have to take it seriously
and and and if you don't it's like i
feel like the penalty
for missing for breaking shabbos is you
miss out on shabbos like i don't work on
shabbos right
email i don't make phone calls i don't
tweet i don't do any of that
not because you know i know that god is
going to punish me or whatever
right because i know it's not good for
me it takes me out of this world in a
good way to be with my friends my wife
my kids my
my family um and so i just think it's uh
it's it might be the same i might be
missing this gene
you know of prayer but it might be to my
detriment and i wonder if there are any
kinds of exercises or
i mean do you meditate i've always
wondered do you meditate or what do you
feel like the connection behind
i don't um i pray uh
and i take long walks although i
generally when i take walks honestly
listen to books on tape
i listen to victorian novels i've
listened to almost all of trollope i
listened to austin
that's and i find that very meditative
although other people may find it boring
as hell
um but uh so that's something you have
in common with noam chomsky
uh what he does that too he does not
meditate but he reads
it oh maybe i should start meditating
um but uh
he says the nicest things about you
rabbi yeah right
he did grow up as the child of a hebrew
teacher in philadelphia so we're not
entirely uh
that's right you know we're not entirely
distant in a certain way but
but uh but i but i do not understand
the the virulence with which i with
which i
read his um his
insistent distancing from his own people
and his own tradition with a with an
edge that is cruel and uh
and and biting and to me very painful
yeah
but that's a separate yeah i guess this
isn't the gnome chomsky hour right no
that's right but it is illustrative i do
think that there's you know when i was
talking to him i'm like this guy he put
a keeper on him and he's you know he's
like one of the
rabbis brought a slaughter
character and yeah if you if you steer
away from the 99
of you know the stuff that you that you
really just find a testable but you know
and i said
look i don't agree with you there are
people that find a lot of what he said
repulsive but i'm just going to talk
about what is interesting to my audience
and what i'm personally interested in
because quite frankly i don't care what
he has to say other than yes
it is true he could have a detrimental
effect but i want to move away from
to a rapid fire series because i know
you have to go in a few minutes right
behind me
i want to tell you one quick thing yes
a rabbi the famous of the 20th century
he said you know when i used to go
around to campuses
and somebody would say to me i'm a
catholic i would know they were a
catholic
and somebody would say to me when a
student would say to me i'm a protestant
i'd know they were protestant
when a student said to me i'm a human
being i knew they were a jew
the escape of jews from their own
tradition
is a constant and painful reality and
chomsky
is a is a particularly um
noxious example well nick force i again
i have to say that
you know and not in his defense but i
think it's to his detriment
he's missed out i agree on an infinite
wealth of interesting and delightful not
only that but i would have said nice
things about him on your podcast
well i'll do well how about this we'll
do a uh we'll do a a a debate
how about a rabbi will be noam chomsky
that would be
that would be ratings gold rabbi uh i
wanna i wanna finish up with a couple of
rapid fire
questions and i do want to get into your
book making a lost matter which is such
a meaningful book to me personally
uh first rapid fire question what would
you be doing if you weren't a rabbi
i i think i would be an english
professor okay not second base
for the dodgers okay fine no no no no
limited limited by talent now when i
grew up i grew up in i was born in
harrisburg i was a baltimore orioles fan
actually
ah but but these days phillies eagles
uh anyway i i don't i limited by talent
i think what i
what i would have done was become a
writer and an english professional well
that proof
you know what the proof is that the
being a professor is the best job in the
known universe rabbi
it's that neil armstrong after he landed
on the moon the very first human being
ever set foot on another world he ended
his career as a college professor
at the university of uh i think dayton
um there you go
the bucket list have you ever heard of
the bucket list sure yeah so is that a
jewish concept
is the bucket list something that you
know a good jew you know i once heard it
said you know like some
talmud was asking his uh his rebbe at
the yeshiva you know
rabbi is it okay if i ride a motorcycle
and the rabbi was like
right yeah hit him upside the head you
know basically it's not like riding a
motorcycle is not a thing a jew does
well
is a bucket list something a jew can do
i actually rode a motorcycle in thailand
when i was on my sabbatical so that's
off my bucket list
um but i will tell you this this is the
closest thing i know to a jewish
version of the bucket list samson
rayfield hirsch was a great 19th century
orthodox rabbi
founder of modern orthodoxy and late in
his life
he told his students that he was going
to go hiking in the alps
and they said rabbi you know you're
yeah i don't know you're in his 80s
whatever why are you hiding me out she
goes because
i'm not going to be living that much
longer and i know after i die i'm going
to come before the ribrona
the master of the universe in other
words i'm going to come before god and
god's going to say to me so
did you see my alps so i like that
as a you know as an idea that there are
certain things in the world that you
should experience if you have the chance
to
because it's a remarkable world is the
multiverse
and one incon incarnation of it which is
called the simulation hypothesis which
basically states that we're living in
this
immense digital simulation that's
promulgated by people deep in the future
and simulating our existence is that
compatible with judaism again
it's an offshoot of the multiverse which
can positive that there's a number of
other universes
is that compatible there's an early
midrash that says that god created many
worlds before he created this one
so i suppose you could fit that into
judaism
i'm always reminded when people talk
about a multiverse this is a simulation
of samuel johnson and barkley
bishop barkley was an idealist he said
everything exists in the mind
and samuel johnson famously kicked a
rock and said i refute him thus
all i can say is if this is a simulation
there there is no evidence i mean i'm
hitting the wall
i don't believe that this is this is a
creation of someone else's mind
um if i'm wrong i'll be wrong later but
this is one of those cases where i think
it might be that common sense
is common sense that's right why would
there be so many kardashians if there
was a simulation
there you go qed as the philosophers say
that's right that's right
um last couple of questions uh what
point in jewish history
would you most like to have been alive
besides now you can't say now because
you're alive now at least
the simulation hypothesis is not correct
um in order in order not not because i
think would be a nice time to be alive
but in order to answer the questions
that i would like to have answered
um since i wrote a brief biography of
king david
called david the divided heart in the
yale series of jewish lives
um i i'm i'm
tremendously fascinated by the character
of david
and boy i would love to go back and and
see him and see what his world was
actually like
uh what is the uh your 11th commandment
um it is what henry james said was the
most important thing in life
he said the three most important things
in life are to be kind to be kind and to
be kind
i think that is the i think that is the
critical
i don't always achieve it but that's
what matters
yeah that goes along with what my
realtor once said location location
location
uh last couple of questions rabbi um uh
if you could get rid of a commandment
if you could get rid of one of them and
he can't say adultery rabbi
okay i'm joking i'm joking rubble uh
if you could get rid of a commandment
you know moses in the ten
what is it the uh ah the great mel
brooks movie where he comes down with 15
commandments
all right exactly right it gets rid of
which one has to be
does that be one of the ten or can it be
one of the 613 it could be one of the
613 yeah i know you
you know the stepmother you know kind of
uh uh being attracted
i'm just kidding here with all these
weird references i'm trying to think you
know i'm a vegetarian so i would
actually add to the commandments if i
could oh you will
okay so yeah i would say i i would say
uh
i would say either either no meat or or
or no factory farming no matter how you
slaughter them
um at least that if you're going to eat
meat at least know
that the animals are not allowed to be
treated cruelly while they are alive
um and and there's too much wiggle room
in some of the kosher laws
and some of the kosher uh and some
animals that are kosher
are are not kosher uh in terms of the
suffering that they
endure before they die and the last
thing i want to just touch on
is uh is your book i almost picked up a
copy of my book but i'll pick up a copy
of your book here this is making lost
matter
very beautiful uh apparently at the end
um you say when we read a book the pages
diminish
we can look ahead and see how far we
ought to go in that sense no book can
reproduce life
because we know the terminus life does
not grant that knowledge
the story could end today or in 50 years
yet age is the visible sign of dwindling
pages
where once we had counted on unbounding
future
now we begin to number the years so the
last question i want to ask you rabbi is
if you could take what one of my kids is
working on called the never dying pill
if you could take a pill that would
allow you to live forever would you want
to take it
if i was the only one to take it no
why not because i don't think that i
would i think that at a certain point
uh it's like tennyson's poem to thonis
you know me only cruel immortality
consumes
i think if i consecutively lost
everyone that i cared about and loved
over and over and over again
the time would come when i would long
for death
very powerful rabbi um well that's
sort of more of a somber note that i
wanted to end on i was going to ask you
a couple questions about uh
about chess uh that we'll have to get to
maybe we could do a part two
and a part three noam chomsky and then
part two i'll take you out on
yom kippur for a nice meal rabbi thank
you so much been such a big influence in
my life
thank you have a wonderful day uh uh
happy holidays happy new year
thank you